hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on apex legends again and
today we're gonna be talking about the
Valentine's Day items that are currently
in the shop that just went live about 20
minutes ago those lies like the V if you
do enjoy subscribe for new I cover the
news of apex legends which means I cover
every single update that's gonna be
going live within the game so that
everyone can be caught up to date of
what's happening within the world of
apex legends and with that let's get
started with today's video so as I said
there's gonna be new and Valentine's Day
items in the shop currently we have the
through the heart for the longbow DMR
any love of the game for the Pathfinder
which is a legendary item each of them
will be costing you 1108 pecks coins
each which is pretty good so it's about
eleven dollars but there's an issue if
any of you have been playing apex
legends for about two minutes you
understand that you can only buy these
apex coins in packs you can't buy a
specific amount so if you're like me and
have zero coins to get the one skin or
one of these items you're gonna have to
be getting the twenty dollar pack and to
get both items you're gonna have to pay
the $40 version because a ten dollar
pack is gonna net you 1,000 coins mean
you're gonna be 100 coins off from
receiving the one skin meaning you have
to buy the twenty and buy it and get a
little left over and if you buy both of
these items then you have to get the $40
version cuz both of them combined is
gonna be costing you 2,200 coins and if
you get the twenty dollar pack it's only
gonna get you 2150 meaning your own
gonna be 50 coins away and having to buy
the extra $20 just for two skins so
super scummy stuff coming from EA cuz I
know they definitely put those purchases
in there it's very EA of them either way
I was gonna show off the skinning game
but my store kept crashing so is a
compromise we're gonna have to show the
item shop picture cuz I got one frame
right before it crashed on me so that's
some good luck also hey guys future me
here by the way as you could tell by the
black and white in the background but
they ended up actually removing the DMR
skin B probably because of the crashing
so as of right now when I'm recording
this video the DMR is actually not in
the shop but I'm assuming when it comes
back maybe after this video is uploaded
by the time you're watching or later on
in the day they are gonna be releasing
it again so I'm assuming that won't be
that will mean that it won't be crashing
again so just a heads up it was doing it
for a bit but they are now fixing it
the longbow skin is bright purple and
pink giving off that Valentine's Day
vibe it also has some accents of gold
with a nice cue heart on the stock and
I'm not actually sure if it's going to
be showing the skin which won't be on
the site or the barrel etc because
Gamze do this where the old the skin is
only on the base weapon if you start
adding a barrel or a stock or a sight to
it then it won't go and transfer over to
that part of the weapon but I could be
wrong that's why I didn't want to buy
the skin so I could show it off in game
to see if it actually does do that and
plus you get a different look of the
skin in game than in the item shop so
let me know if you guys want me to do
that more with some bigger skins not
every single thing that comes up in the
item shop but some stuff like this I'd
be definitely down to buy the skin and
show it off in games see if it's worth
it or not next stuff is the banner frame
for Pathfinder it has a little cute
robot shooting arrows with tons of parts
everywhere and loads of gold sparkles
nothing too crazy but I think it's
pretty cool nonetheless
and it is an animated banner frame which
is also really nice to show off when
you're the champion so honestly not bad
between these two skins but since I
don't play Pathfinder in order I use the
longbow
I prefer the g7 Scout I'm not gonna be
using this at all so I'm definitely not
gonna be wasting any apex coins on this
but if you are just like I said before
do be aware you are gonna have to buy
the more expensive packs depending on
how many items you are going to get from
this just because of how the coins work
and how EA designer purchases yeah guys
it's gonna be the end of the video hope
you guys did enjoy like the V if we did
like I said I will gladly buy the items
in the item shop and show them off in
game because as I said they look a lot
different when you're in game inspecting
it and actually using it than an item
shop so I don't know if you guys want me
to do that more I'll definitely be down
to do that we have subscribed for new I
covered the informational side of Apex
legends that being the news of the game
whenever new heroes or new legends are
dropping new loot new weapons anything
new to the game or any updates that the
devs are thinking about releasing I'll
definitely be posting on the channel so
if you want to get caught up today with
everything happening in the world of
apex legends deal fleece a subscribe to
the channel and with that my two most
recent videos will be on the screen if
you guys do want to check that out with
that guy's dope ever grow stir today
thank for watching the video enjoy those
items if you do want to grab those and
peace out
[Music]
you
[Music]